welcome to the 2022 CMA Awards
[Music]
this is the Super Bowl of country music
you got that right and no surprise here
Luke Combs stays winning and the CMA
award for Entertainer of the Year goes
to Luke Combs
I just couldn't be more thankful I
honestly Blown Away by time I want to
thank country music
for making my dreams come true my
beautiful beautiful wife Nicole our
beautiful four and a half month old son
Texas at home right now taking home the
biggest prize of the Night Luke shares
the love with his family
and winning her first ever CMA award
Miss Laney Wilson and oh yeah make that
too and the CME award for new artists of
the year goes too
[Music]
[Applause]
this was a full circle moment for me and
my family in addition to taking home CMA
gold Laney shared her special occasion
with her father who recently recovered
from the stroke this is the most I've
seen him smile in months since he got
sick and you know of course this right
here means the world to me but also him
having him here tonight with me meant
just as much of course our host kept it
cool all night with some amazing
performances
[Music]
of course paying tribute to one of
country music's greatest the late
Loretta Lynn
[Applause]
[Music]
and the tributes didn't stop there Alan
Jackson was the man of the night taking
home the Lifetime Achievement Award I'm
still living at Honky Tonk dream y'all
making our CMA debut Katy Perry with the
denim hey could this be a nod to Old
Britney Spears and JT valenciaga made
its Mark in Nashville with Kelsea
ballerini and Mackenzie Porter both
looking amazing in their dresses a
popular choice Kim K also wore the dress
at the Vanity Fair Oscars